hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to you
know I love the Looney Tunes who doesn't
they're funny they're clever they're
unique they're absolutely wonderful and
you all know what else I love basketball
again
who doesn't it's fun it's intense it
gives you a rush of energy it's also
absolutely wonderful however you want to
be sure to keep these two elements as
far away from each other as humanly
possible because if you don't base jam
the worst Pizza commercialized
half-baked horseshit that ever hiccups
okay all right I apologize I just really
hate it when Hollywood takes not one but
two of the things that I hold so dear to
me and poisons it undiluted urine filled
backwash that I hate so much so with
that said let's take a look at how these
two wonderful pastimes gets transformed
into the cinematic gang-rape that lies
before us first of all you might be
wondering how the hell did this idea
even come about well in the early 90s
Nike had a brilliant marketing plan for
selling their hottest new item Air
Jordans obviously they had Jordan on
board but they needed something else
that would be sure to grab all the
little kids attention so Nike made a
deal with Warner Brothers to throwing
characters like Bugs Bunny and Marvin
the Martian into their commercials could
you expect oh my foot the ads were a
huge hint and soon Bugs Bunny and
Michael Jordan became America's top
marketing whores sucking dick for Nike
McDonald's toy moguls and too many
t-shirt companies to count Jerusem
painting after this big success the
marketing heads of warner brothers got
an idea what if we turn the commercial
into a movie then by turning the movie
into a commercial thereby producing
commercials for commercials huh it's
like every advertisers what dream a
perpetual marketing money-making motion
machine that has the ability to turn
shit into gold on the Tod coat and the
Space Jam was born the first film that
was quite literally a commercial for a
commercial for commercial but don't
worry they hide that back very cleverly
get your Hanes on lace up your Nikes
grab your Wheaties and your Gatorade
will pick up a Big Mac on the way to the
ballpark subtle but still a movie with
two of America's most treasured icons
was a pretty big deal and we knew that
the heads of Hollywood wouldn't just
throw any crap together for their
money-making prized posessions obviously
so tell us then what's the story
you see these aliens come from outer
space and they want to make a slaves in
Beanpot so we challenge them to a
basketball game but then they show up
and they ain't so little thank yous we
need to beat these guys cuz they're
talking about slavery they're gonna make
us do stand-up comedy the same jokes
every night for all eternity we're gonna
be locked up like wild animals have been
trotted out to perform from wench
lowbrow bunk I've expanded Yuma
challenged aliens it's a too late to get
my money back
okay so the story bugs was trying to get
across starts off with Michael Jordan
after he dropped out the MBA the first
time he dropped out we see him during
those embarrassing years when he
actually took up baseball instead of
basketball and that's not that writing
that that actually happened meanwhile we
traveled to UM outer space where the
evil ruler of a um theme park on the
moon is looking for new attractions so
he sends his aliens to kidnap the Looney
Tunes who live in um the middle of the
earth where the Looney Tunes retaliate
by um challenging them to a basketball
game how many times have we heard that
story
we gotta get new agents we're getting
screwed but before we even get to that
we have to watch dozens of scenes where
Michael Jordan is interacting with his
family suppose it well he went 2 for 5
and lost 30 points in his batting
average oh yeah it's like what's the Met
like us 685 or something oh come on can
you get to the Looney Tunes already what
do you think I'm kind of partial to
purple and gold myself it goes better
with my coloring on second thought go
back to the boring family chicken
chicken chicken one chicken collard
green good on second thought go back to
the Looney Tunes
it's the 700 club on I taught you'd
never ask
judging by those clips you may have
noticed the first problem with this
movie the Looney Tunes aren't funny
they're rude loud obnoxious ly annoying
but they're certainly not funny in fact
the writing for this movie is so
horrible you almost wish the original
bullying tunes from the 50s could sit
there and watch it I'm a curator
but mommy I don't want to go to school
today
I let myself
haha very funny the same problem you may
have noticed with this movie is that
Michael Jordan is not funny he's dull
boring an incredibly bad actor but he's
certainly not fine in fact I don't even
think he knows he's in a movie I think
they just followed him around with
cameras and then painted some cartoon
characters in the background fuck it
getting back to the story that aliens
decided to go back to our world and try
to get some extra strength while there
they sit next to the wife from Everybody
Loves Raymond then the guy who did the
voice for Homer Simpson
how random so the aliens steal all the
talent from some of basketballs greatest
players we're fine it's just some
psychosomatic deal of sudden news and
movement allow another planet Wow it
looks like they took their acting talent
too
so the aliens become giant monsters
which the Looney Tunes can't possibly
defeat so they get the help of Michael
Jordan and his wormy little assistant
played by Wayne Knight who I was
surprised to find out is not a cartoon
character oh yeah so the game is on and
all the Looney Tunes join forces to stop
the evil aliens in a universal Space Jam
which still sounds strange to me I don't
know when I think of Space Jam I think
of that stuff they used in space holes
to block out the radar raspberry so all
your favorites are there for the lineup
including bugs Daffy pork eat as Elmer
Lola Tweety and Marvin but wait a minute
the fuck is Lola oh wait wait wait I
remember from the classic Lola cartoons
but you know with the and the blossom
Lola turns out as a girl bunny they
created to bring in more of the female
demographic unfortunately they didn't
really make her fun silly goofy or zany
in fact they didn't give her any
personality at all they just tried to
pose her off as some sort of strange sex
off which is kind of weird because she
is in fact Arendt
she's not a person she's a rabbit if it
was a person maybe you make a little bit
more sense to make her a sex symbol but
she is in fact a rabbit why would I walk
like a rabbit what sense does that make
rabbits aren't sexy rabbits are food I
mean look at her they dress her in
skimpy clothes then make her wear short
shorts oh and here's the biggest insult
of all they actually gave her
bunny boobies by boobies honey what kind
of sick twisted paren actually give us a
cartoon character bunny boobies I mean
if that Hasenpfeffer hussy actually has
female genitalia what does that mean the
other going to characters have we've got
balls okay all right let me make one
thing perfectly clear to all you more
dubrow's representatives out there we
don't want to fuck buddies I definitely
like to say this we don't want to fuck
buddies I mean we're people therefore we
like to fuck other people I'm sure
there's some small percentage of people
out there they like to fuck bunnies but
that hardly seems like a very profitable
demographic I mean I put it to you have
you ever seen a bunny that you actually
had the hots for that doesn't count
okay so aside from promoting bestiality
to kids the film also has the worst
camera shots in the entire world that is
to say they're all extreme close-ups
seriously I feel like all the characters
in this movie are about to French me
these shots are so close I keep thinking
the cameras gonna hit them in the face
like in the opening of a ladder kill cus
I needed to color so all the way meet
own characters bugs defeat as hoo and so
forth pretty much get their animated
asses handed to them and trust me when I
say no one is fair
do they just beat the shit out granny
dad they just beat the shit out of
granny
they actually tackled punched and kicked
an innocent old lady who never harmed
anyone in her life can I see it again
one more time oh my god I can watch that
forever but unfortunately the movie
continues and turns out that Michael
Jordan and his Looney Tunes are actually
short one player who could they possibly
get oh no bill what are you doing
you still got a career to lose perhaps I
could be of some assistance
go get out there's still time look you
made it through larger than life and he
made it through the man who knew too
little but I just don't think you can
survive this this is why I was born okay
I'm gonna give you the name of a
director here is Sofia Coppola she's
kind of a newcomer but she has a lot of
promise just just think about it very
funny of course it comes down to a tie
game it's up to Michael Jordan to score
the final point but in a stunning turn
of events they actually don't win they
lose the game defining all cinematic
conventions Michael Jordan finds out
that he is an imperfect human being a
fallen hero
he discovers the burden of
responsibility that having such great
power requires but he also finds that
strength comes from the mind and soul
and not just from a black
accomplishments though not the happiest
ending the film teaches children that
even in their darkest moments you can
always find unity in yourself
that my friend is the essence all
mankind not just kidding he makes the
basket of it so the willing to get
Michael back home give the players back
their talent and return to being their
phenomenally unfunny cells but Jordan
still has one last thing to settle Mayan
though he doesn't play basketball
anymore you know it probably doesn't
even have it anymore guys it's only one
way to find out
oh I see it's because of the Looney
Tunes and Michael Jordan came back to
basketball this movie sucks I mean what
were they thinking and what a sane
asylum could this movie possibly be
considered good and one of the amazing
thing is this movie actually had four
writers for writers and not one of them
knew that they were writing
intergalactic patient I mean can you
imagine what the writing session with
these four morons was like I see aliens
I also see Michael Jordan being sucked
down a golf hole and when a basketball
game against Bugs Bunny actually that
explains a lot that's it we're out of
here I'm in the Strausser Critic I
remember it so you don't have to dumb
what a bad movie